foreign
to the minimalist podcast my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we're the
minimalists welcome Alabama here hi
everybody TK Coleman what it is
coincidentally it is a brand new year
this is our first episode of 2023. we
have something
completely different for you this year
this episode there's someone I've been
following for a few years
who has radically changed my
understanding of truth of my own beliefs
of suffering
of what it means to live a meaningful
life
his name is Dr Kapil Gupta
I read a few books of his a few years
ago when I was going through the worst
of my health issues
and I began to form an understanding of
so many things that I was allergic to at
first like in the sense that
oh this is a truth a profound truth but
I wanted to keep it at arm's distance
right because I was afraid of some of
these truths that we're going to dive
into in this episode I want to preface
it though that
this episode might not be for you in
fact TK will say I think that's a caveat
whenever
we release an episode
but maybe I were to pin that caveat with
this this episode probably isn't for you
and that's not a good or a bad thing
but I wanted to record it because
I suffered greatly
and a lot of these insights really
helped me through my own suffering and
so there's a chance that you will get
value
from this episode
if you are suffering and you're open to
some truths Ryan told me this
conversation made him a bit
uncomfortable when he first heard it
delightfully uncomfortable really I mean
because here's the thing when you listen
to someone like Kapil Gupta who is
constantly challenging what what Society
holds to be true or what we're
conditioned to think is true it does one
or two things it opens you up to A New
Perspective or it will root those
perspectives even you know further and
deeper and make them even more true for
you but this this conversation with
Kapil Gupta will absolutely rattle
anyone who listens to it and I'll tell
you
um I'm really looking forward to the
conversation that the three of us are
going to have about the the conversation
you have with Kapil Gupta because
I I have a lot of questions I have a lot
of observations and um yeah I just
really look forward to unpacking
unpacking that so yeah you patrons I
think you're in for an awesome treat
because
um you're gonna hear this conversation
and you're gonna be uh uh you're gonna
be challenged you're going to have
questions you are going to want to
rebuttal and I promise you that um I
will be the rebuttler for you all and uh
we will we will unpack all of the all of
the things that that Josh and Kapil
talked about in this conversation so if
you're listening to the free public
minimal edition of episode
373 right now what you're gonna get is
about half of my conversation with Dr
Kapil Gupta and if you want the entire
conversation as well as the three of us
challenging each other maybe even
disagreeing a bit but ultimately trying
to better understand the truths that
were highlighted throughout this
conversation you can find that over at
patreon.com the minimalists on the
minimalist private podcast or you can
just click the link in the description
you can find the whole conversation as
well as our debrief afterwards before we
dive into it TK what did you find useful
or insightful in this conversation oh
man well I think Kapil would say there's
no requirement for me to find anything
useful or insightful from the
conversation you all had I thought the
conversation was a lot of fun fun in the
way that a game is when you play a game
you're not thinking do I agree with this
move or do I disagree with that move is
that the right move to make you're
available to what's happening and you're
just playing and I think this
conversation was a provocative
invitation to engage reality without
forcing yourself to look at everything
through the lens of prescription a bunch
of shoulds and should Nots and he
manages to challenge Us in this way
without prescribing a how-to method for
doing it and without prescribing this as
something that you ought to do or would
be better for you to do and I just think
it's fascinating so even though this
conversation might not be for you this
conversation also might be for you
because it's an invitation of
possibility one quick programming note
you'll notice some pauses throughout
this conversation and we didn't edit
those out intentionally because there
were moments where I didn't want to
Simply fill the air with Bland
natterings
or try to look smart
and so there were times where I just
pause and waited to see what was going
to come next big thanks to our patreon
subscribers if you subscribe to the
private podcast you're the ones who keep
this podcast 100 advertisement free
because advertisements suck enjoy this
episode with Dr Kapil Gupta and if you
want more from him he has a bunch of
free discourses you can read over at
Kapil Gupta md.com
foreign
thank you for joining me
sure thanks for having me
you know I um came across your work a
couple years ago and since then I have
put together an entire list of questions
that I was hoping to ask the great Dr
kapio Gupta
and I realized that
these were very sincere questions a few
years ago
but these questions began to sort of
answer themselves
as I was exposed to more of your work
and also to just more truths
in my own life and I was going to bring
in that list of questions but I realized
it would be insincere
to ask those questions now because
I don't feel the same
curiosity interest
to those questions and so instead of
doing that I wanted to start at the
beginning I was first exposed to your
work because I read a book of yours
called direct truth
and then from there I started reading
some of your public discourses from your
website
and
I think at first my initial reaction was
anger frustration
um
disbelief of a sort
and I wanted to read
the email the first email I wrote to you
this was a couple years ago back in 2020
and instead of asking you a bunch of
insincere questions I thought maybe we
could talk about
some of these realizations
your books and interviews found me
earlier this year back in 2020 amid some
unanticipated chaos a sudden
hospitalization
over the subsequent months as I peeked
behind the curtain you opened I realized
it's all chaos
and I've been lied to my entire life
I would have pinned that and say I've
also been lying to myself
I Now understand that my beliefs
opinions and methods Cloud the truth
that ego hope culture habit change and
mindfulness
barricade the path to peace that right
and wrong good and bad should and
shouldn't or moralizing constructs that
prevent me from asking questions that
matter
these realizations were particularly
troubling at first because I've spent
the last decade attempting to quote help
people with the quote right Solutions
what nonsense
of course I wasn't ready for this
Insight 20 years ago 10 years ago
even two years ago I thought I desired
the truth but that desire was not
sincere until now
it took me 39 years to get here
well I've known for years that how to's
and prescriptions don't solve real
problems and that attachment is
antithetical for to contentment I knew
these things only intellectually
which prevented me from
understanding
the Kapil uh two years later you
responded with just a few words you said
those are some sincere words wise
realization
and
I thought about it for a couple weeks
and then I responded with this and
here's really what I was hoping to talk
about today
peel I've been contemplating whether to
reply to your thoughtful response
because I don't want to fill your inbox
with Bland natterings however I feel
compelled to say thank you over the past
two years your writings have exposed me
to profoundly difficult truths truths
that at first I wanted to dismiss
because their implications repelled me
what if every solution I've pursued is
actually the problem what if I've been
lied to my entire life
what a fun lying to myself
yeah that was too late a man cannot
unsee a sunrise
your discourses led me to deeper
realizations
fear exists only in the presence of
consequences
freedom
is the only worthwhile thing
all conflict is self-conflict
I'm gonna pause there for a moment
because
I was hoping that we could
talk about
the conflict that we experience in our
lives and I think I spent those first 39
years
mired in conflict that I didn't even
realize it was conflict most of the time
in fact seeking out
conflict in a way I was seeking out my
own
discontent the sort of lack of peace
and
when I stumbled across
your words
it opened up this door that helped me
that supported me in
a deeper understanding
that everything that I was pursuing
was
fruitless to a great extent
and so
I wanted to start with
that first statement here fear exists
only in the presence
of consequences
I don't know if I heard you say that or
if I saw you write it but that was
apparent to me that I was fearing a lot
of things because I was ultimately
afraid
of the consequence
and often that consequence was I was
terrified of what other people
might think of me
can you help me better understand
where that comes from
where what comes from
that that fear of
[Music]
caring so profoundly and deeply
about what other people might think well
let's look it's it's the
it's the world that a human being builds
without knowing that he builds it
because it's the only world he knows
and it's it he he creates he lives in
the larger world and then he creates
smaller worlds out of the larger world
and the smaller worlds are in the form
of relationship in the form of image in
the form of trying to please others and
trying to
um
impress others and gain favor and all of
these things and
um it it it's critical for me to say at
this juncture that none of those things
are wrong none of those things are good
it's
they are just a
a side effect of the consequence of
being worldly
um and any attempt actually to fix those
things just leaves you more and further
and further into worldliness and the
further and further you get into
worldliness the further and further you
drift out to sea so it doesn't really
matter what the detail is
um a worldly life is all suffering
uh it's all misery it you can paint it
however you like you can put on a smile
and say you're happy with your
circumstances or you have a lot to be
thankful for and have a gratitude
journal and all this nonsense if you
wish
um but it's it's just trying to find a
pocket of air within a uh a state of
drowning and and once again there's
nothing wrong with that but whatever
issue you choose is simply a detailed
form of suffering
um because one has become worldly and
one has therefore uh has respect and for
the world and values the world and
therefore he values all the things that
are said within it by its uh
spiritualists and it's self-helpists and
its minions and its experts and he
imbibes that and he reads books and he
listens to media and he hears interviews
and he uh listens to talks and he
imbibes all of that information and he
goes off upon the Journey of what are
fundamentally lies and they're not
necessarily intentional lies in fact I
don't believe that most people are out
to hurt people I don't believe that at
all I believe that most people are
trying to help people most so-called
experts are trying to do good for their
fellow man I firmly believe that
um but the effect remains that it still
all lies and and when I say it's lies I
mean that's no one should ever believe
me on that that's something that they
have to they can examine for themselves
because if they believe me and say well
you're saying it's a lie so then give me
the truth then then it's going to be
everything being dependent upon what I
say and that has no relevance everything
everything comes down to realizations
for oneself
yeah
I
I was one of those Liars without knowing
that I was right
in my late 20s I had sort of climbed the
corporate ladder and achieved some
material success after growing up really
poor and I thought that would complete
me make me happy Etc and obviously as
you've already illuminated here it
it did the opposite and so I I at first
renounced the things the material
success
shunned the accomplishments the
achievements and I realized that in a
perverse way that sort of
tethered me to those things I think of
it as a sort of layer cake of
consumerism and it's possible to trade
in material consumerism for other forms
of consumerism whether that's experience
consumerism or spirituality consumerism
you know we can get rid of our fancy
things and then become consumers of
meditation or consumers of some other
sort of Dogma right but also consumers
of prescriptions and you've written
rather eloquently and I think this is
the thing that is most difficult
to grasp it first but I think as soon as
people
as soon as I got over
this hurdle of prescriptions
it
it was wildly helpful
so can we talk about
the problem with what is a prescription
in the sense of how you use it and what
is the problem
prescriptions are how to's
hacks five-step plans methods techniques
these are the only currency that exists
in the world today
from the domains of the most spiritual
and
uh
spiritual and
so-called sacred to the domains of the
outright materialistic and worldly
it's literally the only thing that
exists there is no such thing as
a domain or an expert or a discipline or
a teaching or a book or anything that
exists anywhere in this on this planet
that is that is not a prescription
whose philosophy is not founded entirely
and solely and exclusively upon
prescriptions
everyone has been conditioned into and
everyone has been brainwashed and the
brainwashing is so complete that even
the so-called wise men fall for it
and one of the central brainwashings is
the idea of how to and it is so complete
that no one would even think to question
it I mean how what else are you going to
ask but how to uh you want to become
happy well how do I become happy you
want to become a successful how do I
become a success you want to make money
well how do I make money how do I do
this and how do I do that and therefore
uh when the when the demand is there the
supply is created and they both feed
each other so it's the blind leading the
blind uh you can examine in your own
life that if everything forget
everything if anything was based upon a
how-to then all you need to do is find
out who became a success read their book
and then you would become equally a
success and as far as I can tell that
doesn't really happen
uh so nothing is this this is how I did
it and you follow these five steps I
mean you can do that for mechanical
things you know you can turn on the
computer and you can maybe uh open and
close you know Venetian blinds because
there's a how-to to that
um things that are mechanical
uh things that really don't mean much
but things that are
um in anything towards a realm of art
anything towards the realm of anything
significant or lasting
or real there's no how-to
and and there's there's no point in
trying to beat that drum
in the same way that there's no point in
beating any drama about anything that I
write about the most futile thing on
earth is to attempt to convince someone
and the reason that people do is because
the experts gain Joy from others
um liking what they say
and they and just like you said earlier
Everyone likes to be liked
so if you given how to and someone says
thank you that helped me it gives you
the ego of the helper and therefore that
makes you feel good and there's nothing
wrong with that there's no evil in that
um it is simply that's just the way that
human beings have learned to live this
is one of their pleasure chases I want
to help I want so and so to like me I
want so and so to give me Applause and
celebrate me and I feel good when I tell
so and so that they should do this and
that and they go doing this and that
um it gives me a feeling of authority
and it gives them a feeling of following
me and all of these all of all of these
layers upon layers of of emotional stuff
um once again none of which is a crime
none of which is evil
um but it's it it is all Pie in the Sky
so you know
how many books have been written about
happiness how many how many books been
written about peace and making money and
uh conflict and relationship and I mean
you name the topic uh there's probably
70 000 books on everything
uh so first of all if if there's
millions of books
just I mean a a decisive
maybe a discriminating mind
look at that just from a very
um bird's eye view and say wait a minute
if books really work then why are there
millions of them
there should have just been one book and
then it would have worked okay fine too
okay fine five okay fine 25. okay fine
200. all right fine two thousand I mean
how long I mean if it worked
then so even if you knew nothing about
nothing
then you could just basic on
kindergarten logic
if something really worked
that it shouldn't keep needing to be
done
so the very fact that there's millions
and millions of a thing
that means it doesn't work
not that it's wrong and not that it's
good and bad not that I believe not that
you believe it's if there was Millions
then then it doesn't work then then you
would have to buy into the logic and
you're free to do so that okay fine
there's 10 million of them they don't
work but maybe the 10 million in first
might bring something and that's fine
you can you can pursue that logic if you
wish I'm not saying that you shouldn't
um it's those are just evidences for the
fact that all of these hacks and methods
and techniques and how to's and
five-step plans they're they're just
they're just tabloids they're just
things to they're just content creation
just to keep the content coming they're
nothing real there it's all for the
masses therefore it's for nobody it's
all for the unseriousness for it
therefore it's for nobody it's all for
the insincere therefore it's for nobody
it's all for the entertainment Seekers
therefore it's for nobody so it and once
again no one should believe a single
word that I say just examine your own
life because you are most certainly a
victim of prescriptions everyone is
by examining my own life I figured out
that a lot of it was it was Misery all
the way down right and it was easy to
mask
it was either it was easy to ignore via
distraction or entertainment and as you
said there's nothing wrong with
entertainment and there's nothing wrong
with prescriptions as well a few days
ago I had to reset a Wi-Fi router and I
pulled out the manual a book and it
helped me with the how-to steps of
restoring the factory settings right but
if I were inventing Wi-Fi there would be
no how-to for that
and
I don't like to get bogged down in
definitions that's something I've
learned from you especially from when
people talk to you they're often asking
a question about like what does it mean
to pursue that or what does the truth
mean and and I see that we get stuck
quite often
on we almost trip over other people's
interpretation so I'm going to read some
more from that email I sent you because
I think it will open up a conversation
about some fairly sincere questions
with each month that passed a new
awareness followed not always from your
words but invariably through the door
you had opened and here were some of
those realizations
excitement is an addiction
I um
I didn't realize how addicted I was to
excitement and we can call it something
else we don't need to Define it but
pleasure chasing
um
the pursuit of happiness I think would
be the way to Veil it in a
culturally virtuous way
the next uh Insight or yeah Insight here
is betterment is a cultural disease this
one was a big one for me because
throughout my 20s I climbed the
corporate ladder
made better money purchased better
things
but along the way fundamentally my life
didn't get better
and then I thought I would better My
Life by getting rid of the things right
and it was another sort of pursuit of of
betterment
and
as soon as I realized that there was
nothing to make better not sure that
circumstance there are some
circumstances that you
can quote unquote improve
but as soon as one
simply seeks to improve grow
it seems that it it creates
more misery
in
the pursuit itself
creates misery and so Kapil can we talk
a bit about excitement
and this disease of betterment
you know one of the things about the
truth which makes it unpalatable for
most is the fact that there are so many
sacred cows and everything is destroyed
but at the end of the day nothing is
left and no one likes to live with
nothing
so I mean at some point a person really
comes to the point where he either he
says it verbally or most likely not
usually it's you know mentally to
himself like well we're going to get rid
of everything like nothing is nothing is
worthwhile then you're talking to me
even getting better as a human being
even that you're going to take away
so like everything
the reason that it's seen as being taken
away is because it was falsely built to
begin with
so all of these things of I mean it's
easy for people to see
that better man in the form of making
more money
won't make you happy
um that's that's easy for people to see
but if you say
betterment in the form of changing
yourself
self-improvement self-development growth
all of these things they're a farce well
that's that's that's a huge that's a
huge leap because that's sacred
what do you mean getting better as a
human being is uh is nonsense
um the and that's why it isn't about
convincing anyone I don't care who gets
it doesn't get it I don't I don't I
don't get any I don't get any um Good
Feeling if if people agree or if they
follow the path of truth I mean that's
great for them I don't get anything from
it so I don't care so I'm not here to
get Applause and I'm not I'm not here
for to get disciples and I'm not here to
start any movement I don't care
um I I'm just interested what what what
what I adore and am devoted to
not because it's good
I don't care about goodness
I'm just devoted to exploring truth
reality what is the truth behind things
and that's not a good thing either
I just am
I don't apologize for it nor do I
celebrate it that's just who I am and
someone else or someone else and there's
no there's no better or worse than
someone else so so the idea of
self-improvement it's all a farce it's
all changed this change that change your
behavior make sure you talk this way
don't talk that way make sure you say
this they don't work
like forget whether you philosophically
believe it or not that's that's a
separate
it doesn't work
so you can you'll be told that
I'll go talk you know go talk nicely to
your enemy and that's fine
as long as you're willing to get kicked
in the face
because when you do that and you get
kicked twice in the face then you'll
come back and say oh well I did what I
was told it didn't work
well you see nothing is partial
everything is whole
right so unless you're willing to go all
the way nothing is real and so all of
these things are just bits and pieces of
things it's like walking into the middle
of a conversation right if so-and-so
says this make sure you respond with a
smile and make sure that you improve
your body language and make sure that
you have good morning routines uh
because so-and-so had good morning
routines I'll give you a thousand guys
who wake up at noon and and are
multi-billionaires
and who are crazy successful okay so
don't give me the ice bath and the
morning routine and the I wake up at
this and I go to sleep at the now if
someone does they do great
but that isn't a something to do
now if you if if you happen to come upon
that concept and it resonates with you
and you just enjoy it you enjoy getting
up early in the morning it makes you
feel X and Y and you enjoy going to bed
at night because the good night's sleep
and then getting up early in the morning
makes you feel refreshed fantastic
that's your own personal experimentation
which led to that great
I mean I I really mean that that's great
but there's no like you should do this
this is good for you if you do this then
you'll get that let me tell you right
now no you won't
it is an absolute lie
anything which comes as a certainty that
if you do this you will get that it's a
complete trap
is there the odd person to whom that
might luck out and happen to sure
but nothing which deserves being written
in a book
so I mean everything is non-linear
nothing is a straight line
nothing is these are the five steps
and you can improve till the cows come
home at the end of the day how you feel
within yourself does not depend upon
your self-improvement
because the world is still going to be
the world
and the situations that you experience
are still going to be the situations
that you experience and you can bite
your tongue and you can you know put
tape on your mouth and you can wait your
10 seconds before you respond and all
these stupid idiotic moronic silly
juvenile kindergarten things you can do
if you wish but they're not real they're
not for someone who wants to get to the
truth behind things not that someone
should
and that's why I say
I don't think most people should stop
looking at spirituality or religion or
self-help or self-development or go to
the motivational speakers or the experts
and I don't think they should because
they're looking for entertainment
anyways so if you're looking for
entertainment
you may as well may as well go to the
self-improvement version of
entertainment rather than going to a bar
that's far more fruitful
so there you could see some benefit on a
relativistic scale
but it all depends what you're looking
for
and so I don't I don't say that no one
should meditate you can if you wish I
don't want you to do mindfulness you can
if you wish
one has to understand that when they
come into my domain what they're coming
into
they're coming into a very biased place
and my bias
is holistically and directly towards
ultimateness truth world class
reality the whole thing the peak of
Everest the ultimate of the ultimate the
ultimate possibility of a human organism
that's where that's everything I talk
about is from there
so I don't have any space or any
interest
or I make no room
for commoners who seek common things who
seek a little bit of this and a little
bit of that and that's perfectly fine
that's not what I'm interested in I
don't care about that and so therefore
could you meditate and get something out
of it yes you can
if you meditate you can get some peace
for 20 minutes a day sure you commit any
crimes of course not
you know that's not a crime so but I'm
looking at everything from
buddhahood
I'm looking at everything from the
ultimate possibility of a human being
both in in profession in skill
development in learning
um in in in life and in internal Freedom
everything the ultimate is the only
thing which interests me I'm not
interested in in the low in the middle
of the road I'm not interested in
dabbling
um so that's where a disconnect can
happen if someone might think that I
think meditation is somehow like this
bad thing and and I and I don't none of
those things are bad it just depends
what you're looking for and who you are
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed or I bet that you'll be fine
without it